a beautiful baby girl she wasn't just
beautiful on the outside you must have
seen her pictures across the media she
was so beautiful on the inside she was a
treasured and adored child
she wanted very few things in life
she wanted to be a doctor
she wanted hockey with her Pals
she wanted to have fun
because that's what all students want
they want to enjoy themselves
and all they were doing was walking home
they were just walking home after a
night out
and like Emma says Emma Weber says
this person must face Justice
it just it just is truly so unfair
but I'll Echo what my husband said
yesterday be kind to each other look
after each other don't have Hate in Your
Hearts
say prayers for my baby girl